heads of state who attended the first
African Union climate Summit said the
continent needs to speak with one voice
ahead of the UN cop 28 meeting in
November we demand a fair playing Ground
for our countries to access the
investment needed to unlock the
potential and translate it into
opportunities we further demand adjust
multilateral development Finance
architecture to liberate our economies
from odious debt and honorous barriers
to necessary Financial Resources
delegates discussed how to harness un
topped resources and translate that to
profit they explode the possibility of
Africa having its own carbon market and
impose a carbon tax the leaders here St
all the right things and had big ideas
about how to tackle climate change but
the bottom line it all comes down to
money hundreds of millions of dollars in
Investments were pledged for climate
related projects the continent is
suffering from some of the most severe
effects of climate change yet it
receives 12% of the funding it needs to
cope we've seen many pledges made on the
floor we've seen announcement made and
even before today there were
announcements made on delivering climate
Finance to the global South to a tune
over100 billion per year this 14 years
ago so I think what needs to be done is
translating those commitments and
announcement to tangible actions on the
ground many delegates say they are
hopeful the Declaration that has been
made will hold and its implementation
will be taken seriously by member states
Katherine soy Al jazer Nairobi
Kenya make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer